vous connaissez avec Lucien aimé blanc
non de réputation de réputation alors
vous publiez Christian l'estavel chez
Robert Laffont nom de code la loutre
comment j'ai infiltré le crime pour les
RG chez votre boulot c'était ça en fait
je tiens indique votre livre s'ouvre
d'ailleurs sur une scène où vous prenez
livraison de 2 kg d'héroïne pur au
moment de la transaction les flics
sortent de partout il sert les dealers
et vous pour faire plus vrai vous prenez
la fuite voilà c'était votre c'est votre
boulot quoi tout à fait
vous écrivez je suis d'une race à part
un pied chez les voyous un pied chez les
condés passe à l'arrière pas de bureau
pas de congés pas de collègues je vis
dans l'ombre je crains autant la police
que les truffes
bien sûr mais je pense que même à la fin
je craignais plus la police que les
truand c'est qu'en fait personne vous
protège quoi
non je crois que personne vous protège
pendant toute la durée du travail
pendant toutes les années puis à la fin
même si on pouvait disparaître ça serait
bien c'est vrai ça Lucien
temps que on les utilise dans les
protège et puis que dès qu'il y a le
moindre
on laisse tomber quoi tout le monde se
laver les mains il y a le problème du
statut c'est à dire qu'il y a aucun il y
a aucun statut il y a aucune couverture
il y a des députés qui ont essayé
pendant un moment de de de monter
justement un système de contrôle pour
avoir un petit peu voir tout ce qui se
passait dans avec le niveau des indices
mais à aucun moment ça a été ça n'était
accepté
alors comment en êtes-vous arrivé là
Christian ESTAVEL d'abord petit enfant
assez heureuse jusqu'au jour où votre
mère se suicide après la mort de votre
mère votre père ce clochardise on vous
enlève à lui vous êtes mis dans des
institutions maison de correction vous
devenez voyous et un jour vous débarquez
à Pigalle où vous rencontrez Franck le
videur de l'érotica qui commence à vous
proposer des coûts alors premier coffre
premier butin premier séjour
à Fresnes à 16 ans alors la sortie de
Fresnes premier flingue premier braquage
première sensation de toute puissance
évidemment un flingue dans les mains
c'est l'erreur qui tue on est les
maîtres du monde quoi bien sûr c'est ça
c'est l'erreur malheureusement quand on
a 20 ans c'est facile une arme ça se
trouve facilement et on a l'impression
que qu'on tient tout au bout du canon
alors vous êtes arrêté vous vous
retrouvez à Fleury-Mérogis à 20 ans vous
risquez 20 ans mais vous y échapper à
cause de votre jeune âge au moment des
faits tout à fait je suis encore mineur
voilà alors pendant la préparation du
procès vous sympathisez avec le patron
de la PJ de Versailles c'est lui qui
vous branche avec Thierry bonnet au
fonctionnaire des renseignements
généraux et vous dites c'est l'homme qui
va changer mon destin en fait oui c'est
l'homme qui va changer mon destin et
quand on se rend compte pour la première
fois je suis convaincu que je vais
rendre service je vais payer ma dette
on discute comme ça il me dit c'est une
façon de payer ta dette une dernière
fois tu devrais venir un peu avec nous
on a besoin de gars comme toi et je suis
convaincu que je vais travailler 7 mois
un an pas plus le temps de remonter
quelques quelques petites filières à
l'époque qui est importante et je me
suis senti obligé d'y aller je pense que
quand on vous dit vous êtes capable et
vous pouvez aider il y a pas de solution
quoi j'ai pas j'ai pas décidé d'être
indiqué j'ai dit j'ai pas le choix à moi
étant donné que j'ai la possibilité de
d'infiltrer ce type de réseau alors le
gars vous dit tu n'auras ni gloire ni
gratification tu ne référeras qu'à moi
s'il se passe quelque chose en des
frontières je pourrai rien pour toi si
ça en France je te laisserai pas tomber
sauf que c'est pas c'est souvent pas le
cas ouais c'est clair avec le temps
Lucien avec le temps on est tout seul ah
oui ben vous savez les relations avec
les indices c'est ambigu et les juges
pas n'entendre parler d'ailleurs archite
tant que ça va bien beaucoup donc il
reste plus que la démarche du
fonctionnaire qui traite cette
informateur où il se mouille ou il se
mouille pas ou il a les possibilités de
couvrir ou pas courir c'est très délicat
ce que je veux dire c'est que moi j'ai
eu des patrons j'ai eu de la chance de
tomber sur de très bon patron je dis ça
parce que d'autres ont été tués dire que
la fin de contrat c'est la mort
les deux derniers ont été j'ai eu
beaucoup de chance c'est devenu des amis
depuis et quand ça y est j'ai eu chaud
quand vraiment c'était ça devait être
mon tour ils ont été là Lucien c'est
vrai que un indique qui a fini de servir
la police peut le faire tuer bon je
crois pas mais en le balance comme ça
non non mais attendez alors là moi je
vais répondre je suis désolé en 95 je
suis balancé par un mec de la DRG il
sait que je suis en train de travailler
je suis avec des équipes à l'époque j'ai
la chance ce jour-là de pas être avec
eux de travailler pour eux sur Paris
bien sûr je suis mort bien sûr c'est
bien sûr si j'ai pas un coup de fil de
ma famille qui me dit mais on vient de
lire libération c'est fou ce qui arrive
c'est toi et si je prends pas mon ma
voiture direction Bruxelles où
j'abandonne tout femme enfant tout le
monde et et deux jours après je suis en
Afrique donc voilà si j'ai passé de
chance là je suis mort comme d'autres
donc je vous dis ça on travaille pas
pour une administration surtout pas
parce que on a tendance à vite vous
oublier on travaille pour des hommes ça
gagne combien indique là par exemple moi
j'ai gagné 15000 francs par mois non
je vais dire on vit on vit dans le
système dans lequel on
infiltre donc mais mais mais
officiellement 15000 francs par mois
c'est pas cher non c'est dangereux
non sérieux c'est pas c'est ça mais moi
si vous voulez à l'époque les années que
j'avais
on les courait sur des affaires de
stupéfiants
à la différence c'est que moi j'avais
pas d'échange mais lui il avait pas dit
j'avais pas d'échange parce que là quand
un échange il y en a qui se paye sur la
drogue sur voilà c'est l'indicateur de
base
j'étais balancé par des indicateurs qui
qui était dans par exemple à Nice ou à
Marseille qui me balançait qu'à aller
voir le flic de service avec qui ils
étaient pointés et qui me balançait en
contrepartie ils ont le droit de vendre
un peu de dope ils ont le droit de faire
marcher une fille et pourquoi vous aviez
pas d'échange vous parce que moi j'ai
démarré comme ça d'entrer ça a été un
salaire qui m'a été donné on m'a fourni
de quoi prendre ma première voiture je
suis parti j'ai commencé dans le
terrorisme j'ai pas commencé dans la
pègre pas du tout j'ai dévié dans
l'intègre après parce que quand un
ministre dit on arrête ça Lucien peut le
dire on arrête dans la seconde le gant
laisse sur le terrain où il est on
l'abandonne de personnes parce qu'il y a
des incroyable c'est que des moments par
exemple vous allez en prison pour
montrer aux autres que vous n'êtes pas
une balance vous êtes obligés séjour en
prison
en réalité on est obligé de mentir et ce
qui était très difficile pour moi c'est
que ma façon de vivre faisait penser à
ma femme que j'étais un voyou et je suis
désolé de le dire mais une femme abandra
plus sur un mec qui donne l'impression
d'être un voyou que d'être un indicateur
de police ou un flic à 15000 balles par
mois un flic qui qui a son petit salaire
et qui vit en HLM il est pas [ __ ] il
est pas [ __ ] et votre femme elle a
jamais su vous étiez indique en fait non
non elle a pas compris elle a eu très
très peur c'est que quand j'ai eu ma
première affaire quand j'étais raté la
première fois
mon premier patron a sorti est sorti un
petit peu de l'ombre et s'est mis devant
elle et là elle était convaincue que
j'étais dans un dans un système de
barbouze et avait eu plus peur autre
chose alors qu'est-ce que c'est votre
plus grand exploit en tant qu'indique
c'est l'histoire de la camorraine ouais
je pense ouais parce que c'est du long
terme et puis j'étais 24 heures sur 24
avec eux j'ai mis plusieurs mois donc
vous êtes rentrés dans la banque j'ai je
me suis complètement fondu dans le
système il a fallu John leur confiance
j'éteins un bon
travail c'est quelqu'un de un bon petit
soldat mais aujourd'hui par exemple ces
mecs de la caméra vous avez balancé ils
ont sûrement des copains vous avez pas
peur qu'il vous flingue ça fait partie
des risques aujourd'hui non mais bien
sûr mais non attendez moi je dis
chacun traîne son cancer dans la vie
malheureusement j'ai pas de remède
aujourd'hui j'ai eu ma vie je me je
l'assume avec toujours les mêmes
inquiétudes mais arrivé un moment on vit
pas avec on y pense plus quoi
vous avez gagné quoi dans tout ça pas
grand chose c'est pas grand chose l'état
de problème pas grand chose un casier
judiciaire noir
des soucis familiaux importants des vie
brisés familialement que je reconstruis
maintenant doucement mais facilement
vocation à recommander aux jeunes qui
nous regardent ce soir jamais jamais non
non attendez moi ce que je veux dire
c'est que
si j'avais su tout ça si quelqu'un
m'avait expliqué le problème c'est
énorme d'entrée j'aurais jamais fait ça
jamais je pensais que servir il y aura
une petite reconnaissance au bout il y a
on nous aurait apporté quelque chose au
moins la tranquillité mais rien au
contraire je crois que même à la limite
je vais vous dire il y a le mépris ça
j'en suis conscient parce que vous êtes
une balance et même les flics mes prises
de balance même si elle les utilise
Lucien non ça dépend lesquels ça dépend
lesquels il a travaillé c'était un très
un très bon flic de Hergé un mec bien
qui a pas fait la carrière qui méritait
aussi parce que les mecs bien en général
ils sont cassés
il y en a qui arrivent quand même enfin
bon donc c'était à refaire vous referiez
pas
si c'était refaire la première opération
je la refais ouais parce que j'ai pas le
choix je crois que quand on vous dit que
vous êtes une des personnes qui pouvait
peut-être les aider dans un cadre de
trouver des explosifs et des armes et
qu'on sait qu'il y a des explosions dans
Paris on fait comment et après c'est un
problème personnel j'aurais préféré pas
être la jour là c'est tout et pour être
sûr de ne rien rater de innarditude
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu